so we're here on what day is this this
is day 11 of a 20 day shoot ah okay and
dig 11 what does that usually look like
usually or on this shoot so this is a
fast and furious shoot and almost
everyone on the shoot from cast to crew
a tizzy on that the entire list is we
have people that are working man that
are so much more above arc it was so
much above our pay grade then then what
we'd normally get on a 1.5 million
dollar film and so how day 11 looks
today here at this shoot is we're pretty
calm but we're shooting out it's we're
at an interesting juncture right now
because in the next couple of days we
move on into almost an entirely
different cast we're shooting at our
grownups basically we're shooting out
our mom dad doctor all of that and
moving on to our teenage cast in the
next couple of weeks which is really
interesting I haven't necessarily
experienced that where you have such
emotion in terms of moving from one cast
to another so this isn't interesting
this is an interesting day in terms of
trying to get a lot of work done
interesting because then the when we get
the teenagers of all there will be
course Guardians or teachers and things
on set all of our I say teenagers but
it's really it's it's we have over 18 to
play teens so and that will work for
this movie because our butter is is late
high school aged in terms of what the
the age the character plays so yeah we
don't have to necessarily deal with us
with the minors onset and all of that we
have two days that we have minors on set
and that's towards the end of this week
because we are all over the valley this
this week okay we need to take on a
project what are some of the first
things you do when you see
to something what are you doing
initially I'm a very script driven when
I take on a project I'm very scripted
driven and writer director driven I love
working with a writer director and Paul
brought me this at the book form so this
is adapted from a young adult book
called butter by Aaron Jane Lynch and
and I read the book before prior to
Pollock
prior to Paul adapting it and I was
drawn to it for the social good that it
potentially could do and I wanted the
big things that I take into
consideration in doing a movie is the
why why are we doing it you know why are
we what kind of conversation will this
have what does it tell us about either
ourselves or human condition or a social
issue and this has got so many issues in
good ways that we need to talk about so
it was an opportunity to have to engage
in critical and cultural conversations
that we ought to be having interments
some of the biggest mistakes you may
have made on for second third project
you worked on and how you make sure to
never duplicate that or what red flags
on the poor gosh that's a great question
it's interesting because as you grow in
the industry the realm of what you take
on grows and expands so I came out of a
history of being a development executive
and so that process was taking a book
and helping the producer and/or the
writer director figure out how to break
it down and how to get the fullness of
the book and that internal journey
externalized into script form so when I
first started out my world was very much
worried too towards the script getting a
script right and then once we got the
script right the actors were to come so
in a sense I've had a slow learning
curve and then I got dropped in the deep
end pretty quickly and worked on some
great movies really quickly early in my
career
but my response to my responsibilities
grew and grew and grew as I had more
movies behind me more days on set more
time in a casting room and understanding
what cast would work together and how it
should look like I don't know if I I
could say right off the top and I had
major mistakes that we've had we've had
major mistakes and scheduling which is
one of those thing that was one of the
things I was thinking of in terms of
prior to when at early in my career
there were movies that we probably shot
out of order in an unhelpful way I mean
out of we always shoot a movie at border
but I mean that the order that we had
chosen to shoot it in wasn't the best
order for the creative aspect of the
movie and so for me as a producer one of
things that I want to do fully is
protect the creative and so protect the
story protect the director protect the
the actors and let everyone do their
fullest best work and sometimes you can
really get in the way with some of the
technical stuff that you didn't think
through and you didn't solve so as I've
gotten smarter and as I've gotten more
experienced hopefully the movies will
get better and better in a sense where
Fuller has an experience so less
mistakes just a lot slow moving is slow
learning in a sense we used to rugby as
someone who's very resourceful were you
always this way or would one of your
parents very resourceful and you sort of
saw that my parents were completely
different my parents come from a
scientific background
um yeah I think there is there's I think
you find your path in the industry
according to serve where your head
gravitates to and so I've done a number
of things both in terms of I was a
casting director I worked on the
literary side of things and and then
growing into my role as a producer you
do have to be resourceful you have to
sort of be able to negotiate emotions on
set off of set make people feel safe
make people feel heard and then figure
out how to get the things done that we
need to get done and so what I always
say is that as a producer I don't have
to do everything but I catch and release
you throw me the ball I'm gonna throw to
the person who should take care of it
tell me what needs to be done and I'll
throw it over there and that's a lot of
it and so there's a level of maybe
resourcefulness but then also somewhat
quick thinking or just knowing oh you
can take care of that you can do this I
trust you to do that and I think that is
that's a specific ability that you might
just simply have or not have
it's like it's you we gravitate to what
serves us the best I think I'm where
we're happy and that's where we'll excel
so knowing where to delegate not not
trying to take all of it on and you like
this super person right exactly because
if you take everything on you will mess
so many things up and you know and
basically as a producer on a movie we
have a team of specialists everyone's a
specialist and everyone stay on a good
set everyone stays in their lane and
that doesn't mean that we're not
collaborative it means that we're
skilled at what we do you know whether
you're a publicist or you know whether
you are a grip and we've seen some of
the grips drop down out there wrap that
back behind the window but that's what
they do the electricians the gaffers
that's what they do and they know more
about that than I do
so I might observe something and then I
know who to talk to about it and I know
who can get it done the best most
expediently who should be taking care of
that and it's my job to make sure it's
taken care of and thrown off to the
right person and making sure that that
is indeed accomplished but if I try to
do something that's outside of what I do
best
we're sort of script story cast bringing
it all together in a sense I'm once you
damage the movie because I'm not letting
people be the experts that they are
handling rewrites during production is
it easier to know in the beginning
versus in the middle that's interesting
on this movie this is such a short shoot
at 20 days and it comes from a book so
we aren't doing too many rewrites of
material difference you know every time
once in a while when an actor comes in
that might have a different voice on the
role than we were expecting and so some
of the scene work might change a little
bit just according to you what they
bring to it and so those are done on the
fly other rewrites happen simply because
we couldn't get a location or with the
Woolsey fire one of our locations burned
you know so now we have to think about
what can we do it's not going to be the
same scene but what can take that place
and so that scene will exist in the
movie hasn't been written yet it will be
before we shoot it but a lot times
production rewrites are responding to
what your the situation you're finding
yourself in production whether it is the
specificity of an actor voice whether
it's the chemistry between two actors
whether it's the loss of a location or
whether we're running we're running
behind schedule and we have to combine a
couple scenes but in this situation on
this sort of quick-quick kind of shoot
we want to be as on top of our game and
shoot what we have and feel secure and
confident in it so that's part of my job
is before we shoot to make sure the
script is ready so that we don't have to
do any unnecessary tweaks or we don't
have to develop it further but we do
have the ability to be responsive to the
things that are thrown at us so what is
your exact title on butter I am one of
the producers
I'm producing with Jay Todd Harris and
Paul Kaufman who's also writing a
directing the movie and so when they
approached you did you already read the
book or you were you Paul and I had met
and he had said hey I have a book you
wanna read I want Paul and I had met and
he had said hey I have a book I want you
to read and he passed it on to me and I
read it that weekend so we haven't
worked together before but I love
working from book adaptations or working
on book adaptations and I love the
teenage space so it was a natural fit
for me and I have a teenager so it's it
I get to investigate it from that
perspective and so I jumped on when it
was still at the book level because I
was really intrigued with the book and
the book has an excellent structure for
adaptation so some books are really
resistant and you have to spend a while
thinking about them in terms of how are
we going to make this into a movie and
how can we change what this very
internal structure of a book is to the
structure of a film script so that we
can actually shoot it and make sense of
it this book had a structure that you
could see the film pretty easily and
Paul did a really good job of carving
out the characters carving out the
plotline carving out the screenplay so
that it allowed room for the actors to
come in and grow the story basically a
lot of the y-a books today or I'm some
of them are actually better than yeah
for more absolutely a lot of the I think
a lot of the why a books make excellent
movies and in a sense they the why a the
why a genre tends to be more adaptable
than a lot of much more internal
complicated grown-up fiction or whatever
it may be in a sense I think because
there's a level of there's a level of
art to both in terms of the crafting of
a Hawaii a novel and the level of
crafting to a novel meant for an older
audience in a sense but we can all
identify with why a novel so no matter
what because we all were adolescents so
there is a level of that journey we've
all been through it
I'm sorry you said you were in a
literary space for a while okay and so
when now now having that and then also
being in in the film and television
realm what do you notice in terms of
mistakes that writers often make that
that if they could kind of just tweak
something could save a lot of time and
money there's no writing to me is not
anything that you can tweak easily you
know and I always find that really
interesting because when a development
executive gives a note to a writer but
it's really funny the process that goes
through because you can give her a note
to a writer and you're like in the third
act this could they do this instead of
that that and you'll have the writer
looking like yeah and but when I see
behind their eyes as they are flipping
through all the cards of how that
affects everything in the chain back to
page one so I have a lot of respect for
writers and I think it's a really
difficult job in profession and
obviously difficult to make a living in
it but difficult to do well and
brilliantly and I've been lucky that
I've worked with a lot of brilliant
writers and I've enjoyed that but it is
I think you know if I could say that
there was a mistake that writers make is
it's not giving themselves the time or
space to listen to how they add to a
story or a situation that they write
what they think that the market wants if
they think that will sell without
actually finding something that is that
makes them excited about the telling and
that has a personal resonance with them
so especially younger writers they have
to learn it's cliche but they have to
learn how to find their voice and they
have to value the fact that no matter
what their age or experience level
they've got something of value to bring
out and so the key thing is not to
develop what other people have done but
to work on developing your voice and
I've never met a writer who isn't a
reader the most significant writers I've
ever worked with our very well-read
individuals and I love that
because you have to get you have to feed
the well somehow you have to get ideas
and you understand so much more about
that internal space you want to live
through when you're diving into it
regularly with good books you said your
son your excuse me you said your parents
were in the sciences hmm do you think
having grown up watching maybe two
people using more of a left brain theory
of how they view the world and different
things has helped you because isn't this
more of a right brained sort of yeah
absolutely I think I think that it has
influenced the producer side of me
having grown up with more technically
minded parents because I can observe the
creative and enjoy the creative and
myself in a sad sad war with my writers
and/or my director whoever comes into
the team in a sense but part of my job
is to keep them on a path and keep them
organized and so to find the steps that
we need to take to get a character
through their journey on the writing end
to get a script through production on
the producing end or the practical
production end and then once we're in
the filmmaking to work with my crew in
terms of figuring out each individual
step that we need to take so that we've
got a movie that we can cut together you
know so absolutely there's an analytical
side that I think has to come from my
parents I can see the mixture of both
yeah no it's great yeah that's great and
it probably helps you to think on your
feet yeah absolutely it's an intense
situation absolutely because you sort of
you you I think I think ATS or assistant
directors are the Masters of this so
staying calm in the fire and getting out
how to resolve the mess that might be in
front of you when you came in today so
though we've had a few fires today and
that happens and one of the biggest
things that you have to do is not be
reactive because I need to make everyone
else feel safe around me okay we've got
this handled we gotta figure out we this
is what we're gonna do and this these
are
changes that we can implement in our day
or in our structure or in our movies so
that we can get what we need to get and
not lose any time so there is absolutely
sort of there is absolutely a perhaps a
cold or detached aspect because you
really care passionately about what
you're doing and you want everyone else
to to to think proactively and not
reactively
in a sense so part of your job in terms
of producing is to lead that thought
process as much as you can and stay calm
do you remember the first set you ever
walked on to whatever role it was gosh I
have a when I first started in the
industry I worked for a busy producer
and he had a jumble of movies all going
all at once and I can't remember what
order things shot in because the order
that things get released in are not
necessarily the order that you shot them
in because some movie might get held for
I think my first set I was on the movie
was actually held for a release for
about a year and a half and and then
there's some movies that take a really
long time to come together in other
movies that go super quickly one of the
sets that I loved being on early on was
another teen movie called 13 which was
Catherine Hardwicke directorial debut
and that was you know talking about
writers having experience and no matter
what age you are having a story to tell
that was really hit home with that one
because it was co-written by a 13 year
old girl at the time and that Nikki Reed
had co-written the script with Katherine
and it was a lot about I don't wanna say
Nikki's life it was it was a dramatized
account of sort of an internal space
that she was in at the moment but that's
that I think I have the most memories
from that set my sort of the if I think
about sets early on that was one
my early experiences being onset and
learning about what it means to be on
set and how to get that one you need to
get done we always hear that there's
certain projects that maybe there were a
labor of love for everyone involved and
just the sort of cohesiveness and the
the family environment versus others
that maybe look good in the trades but
it wasn't that experience absolutely so
can you talk about some times what it is
that that really develops I guess it
could go south to if it's absolutely
I mean honestly just because it's
somebody's passion project doesn't mean
that's going to be a good experience in
fact it can go wildly the other
direction so you have to be careful you
have to be careful about the people that
you're choosing to play with in a sense
and collaborate with but yeah I have
been fortunate enough to work on a lot
of movies that you would characterize as
a labor of love this one would be
characterized as a labor labor of love
no one's getting paid their full rate no
one's getting paid what we're getting
paid what we got paid when we first
started in the industry and we're here
because of the subject matter we're here
because of the themes and everyone
that's participating in the movie is
doing it for the same reasons we're
doing it for the you know the the
conversation that can happen afterwards
we're doing it for the quality of the
script and the project and we're doing
it for each other in many cases and yes
there are those movies that you are
cashing the paycheck you know that
become the paycheck job that that you
don't necessarily have as much of an
emotional attachment to and those movies
are harder to get through in a sense
simply because you're showing up for a
job whereas most of us are here because
we love film and we love making movies
and you'd like to make a movie that you
are deeply proud of on many levels
and that doesn't have for me yes I love
teenage dramas I love that world it
doesn't have to be change dramas could
be a horror movie or something like that
if you love that world that's going to
be the most satisfying job in the world
to you but yeah there are those movies
small Lea
of love deeply satisfying when they work
horrible when they don't but I've been
lucky